the first thing you notice here
are the locks there are locks
on every door this is our airlock
because a lot of the young people are
detained it's just an extra security
measure
so one door has to lock before the other
opens i see okay
inside it's an uneasy combination of
children's ward
and prison wing
50 milligrams of circulating which is an
antidepressant
50 milligrams of quetiapine it's a
antipsychotic for low mood and suicidal
ideation
this is a place where severe illness
meets
severe treatment
should we cover it up just so it doesn't
get infected yeah yeah
i've got to clean it off anyway come on
[Music]
at least this will stop anything getting
into it
so this is horizon ward this is a 10
bedded unit
six of these beds are for eating
disorders
it's 7 am and night staff hand over to
the day team
she did tie ligitra at 10 o'clock um it
was removed by the ligature knife
physical observations were completed
there were no concerns it was quite
tight so she was gasping for breath
like afterwards she did have a brief
period of head banging at 11 o'clock
we've followed the management plan went
in every five minutes
horizon is a secure psychiatric unit
for children and young people
and meal times can be difficult in a
place where no one wants to eat
it's the most difficult part of the day
first patients are offered food
if they refuse they're offered this
what's in it ultimately calories but
more than that it's like all the
nutrients
so vitamins minerals everything that the
body needs to sort of
function on a day-to-day basis
the pandemic is fueling an alarming rise
in eating disorders in the past year
cases
have doubled and demand for beds on
wards like this one
is up by a fifth she won't
come out at the moment sometimes it's
not long before they discover that a
patient
is refusing to eat are you sure there's
nothing we can do to help
because i know it's really difficult
when you try and beat it don't we not
come out for a little bit
nurse cat tries to support the youngster
but time has run out 15 minutes
draw the feed up and bring her out does
she know
yeah the clock is ticking yeah so the
young people are aware of it
they know the timings really well
this is what we call an ng tube it's
inserted through the nostril
goes up and then down the esophagus into
the stomach
and it allows us to syringe feed
it's the only way um either you do
something
quite brutal or you let a 14 year old 15
year old
become so physically compromised that
they could ultimately die or go into
organ failure
the eating disorder anorexia nervosa has
this young girl
in the tightest of grips
supported by nurses she's taken to a
room
and behind this door that high calorie
formula
is injected into the feeding tube
i don't know how to feel about it really
having having witnessed it this is the
end of the process and we've just seen
that young girl being marched down that
corridor by nurses
who describe this as not a battle
between nurse and patient
but a battle between nurse and eating
disorder
this girl doesn't want to eat but now
she's being forced to eat
we're seeing a massive increase in young
people that are coming in and saying i
tried to get better at home
and the support just wasn't there
because the community teams are
absolutely backlogged
people aren't having as many
face-to-face appointments everything's
done over
like online and i think a lot of our
young people can say it's so easy to lie
and say you're fine on an online
appointment and it's not until
they get to the point where they're
probably bordering on coming in here
that we realize how severe things
actually
are but there's a problem
there just aren't enough of these places
to meet this surge in demand
and so a crisis is now emerging
nick martin sky news
you